nos dicen dado gdx es igual a la
tangente de x 3 y sobre 26 encuentra la
g inversa de x y quieren que escribamos
eso aquí y también quieren que
encontremos cuál es el dominio de g
inversa de x el dominio de g inversa de
x tengo mi pequeño cuaderno de apuntes
aquí así que intentemos resolverlo
intentamos descifrar lo que es que
inversa de x ésta es gx así que que
inversa de x déjenme escribo aquí
x
dado que x es igual a la tangente de x 3
y sobre 26 así que que inversa de x
esencialmente puede intercambiar la x
con la inversa de x y la gtx por una
equis y resolver para que inversa de x
puedo escribir eso así
x es igual a la tangente
inversa
sí
e inversa de
x
menos
sobre 2
así que resolvamos paraje inversa de x
de hecho los invito a que paren el vídeo
e intenten obtener el resultado por su
cuenta
vamos a restar seis de los dos lados
para deshacernos de este seis de aquí
así que quedaría
x
- 6
es igual a la tangente
inversa de x menos 3
sobre 2
ahora obtengamos la tangente inversa de
los dos lados de esta ecuación entonces
la tangente inversa del lado izquierdo
de la ecuación es
la tangente inversa
x
- 6
y en el lado derecho la tangente inversa
de tangente y si bien limitamos el
dominio de una manera correcta y
hablaremos de eso más adelante será el
argumento que tiene la función tangente
entonces si limitamos el dominio de
manera correcta tangente
tangente inversa
tangente
algo digamos teta
será igual a zeta
y una vez más si de limitamos el dominio
si de limitamos los posibles valores que
puede tomar teta en la manera correcta
entonces asumamos que estamos haciendo
eso entonces la tangente inversa de la
tangente simplemente será lo que tenemos
aquí adentro va a ser esto va a ser
inversa de x menos
espn
sobre 2
y ahora ya estamos en lo último para
obtener g inversa de x simplemente
sumamos 3 piña entre 2 a los dos lados
entonces obtendremos de hecho déjenme
intercambiar los dos lados g inversa
x es igual a la tangente inversa de x
menos 6
y le estamos sumando tres villa los dos
lados así que este lado está ahora de
este lado así que es más tres y sobre
dos más
sobre 2 y ahora dejen de escribir eso
para que lo pueda recordar porque lo voy
a quitar de mi pantalla así que tan que
está inversa de x menos 63 pin sobre 2
dejen de escribir eso entonces se
inversa de x será la tangente inversa
creo que lo debo describir así la
tangente inversa
de x menos 6
y si me interpretó correctamente
tangente inversa también puede ser arco
tangente de x menos 6 más
sobre 2
y si lo interpretó correctamente
y ahora debemos de pensar cuál es el
dominio de ge inversa
cuál es el dominio de g inversa de x
pensemos en eso un poco más el dominio
de g e inversa de x y solamente pensemos
en qué es lo que está haciendo la
tangente entonces la función tangente si
nos imaginamos un círculo unitario si
nos imaginamos un círculo unitario
este es un círculo unitario podemos
imaginarlo como círculo unitario
tiramos por el bien de esto que este es
un círculo unitario este es el eje x
y este es el eje
si formas un ángulo theta si forman un
ángulo que está aquí
la tangente de theta es la pendiente de
este rayo terminal del ángulo
del rayo terminal del ángulo formado por
este rayo y este rayo a lo largo de la
positiva del eje x entonces la tangente
de teta es la pendiente de aquí es la
en 100
de aquí
y podemos obtener la tangente de
cualquier theta excepto por unos cuantos
podemos encontrar la tangente de éste
clave este
la de este inclusive la pendiente de
éste
puedes obtener la pendiente aquí
pero el punto donde no puedes encontrar
la pendiente es cuando la línea se va
directamente hacia arriba cuando la
línea se va directamente hacia arriba o
cuando se va directamente hacia abajo
esos son los casos cuando no la puedes
encontrar cuando la pendiente se
aproxima a infinito positivo o negativo
entonces el dominio de la tangente
el dominio de la tangente entonces él
minute
es esencialmente todos los números
reales todos los números
excepto
tú
múltiplos de y sobre voy a decir y sobre
todos más múltiplos de pib excepto
sobre todos más múltiplos de
p
donde acá puede ser cualquier número
entero hasta negativos porque si estás
en pie sobre 2 y le sumas pasa
directamente a estar acá abajo si
agregas otro vas aquí si restas para
regresas aquí abajo resta uno más y
llegarás de nuevo arriba
este es el dominio pero tú puedes dado
este dominio tu puedes obtener cualquier
número real entonces el rango
el rango aquí
todos
todos los reales
porque puedes obtener cualquier
pendiente aquí puedes incrementar theta
si quieres una pendiente muy alta
reducir theta si quieres una pendiente
negativa así que puede realmente obtener
lo que sea ahora cuando hablas de la
tangente inversa cuando hablas de la
tangente inversa por convención vas
bueno para hacer a la tangente
invertible para que no tengas múltiples
elementos de tu dominio mapeando al
mismo punto del rango porque por ejemplo
este ángulo de aquí tiene exactamente la
misma pendiente que
que este ángulo de aquí
y si tú tienes dos te estás mapeando a
la misma tangente si no restringe su
dominio para que solo tengas una de
ellas no se podrá invertir
y entonces por convención la convención
es que para poder invertir la tangente
se tiene que restringir el dominio
here
el niño
en el intervalo d
menos
sobre 2
sí
para poder construir la tangente inversa
a la tangente inversa le puedes meter
meter cualquier número real por lo que
él
i
de la tangente inversa es dominio esto
solamente es por convención porque
pudieron escoger pudieron los tres
quieren dominio de la tangente de tal
manera que hubiera un solo teta en el
dominio que mapear a un elemento
específico en el rango pero la
convención es la tangente inversa puede
bueno la convención es restringir el
dominio de la tangente entre menos pi
sobre dos y sobre dos entonces el
dominio de la tangente inversa son todos
los reales
22 reales
pero su rango está restringido
y eso es por convención será d
- pie sobre todos
y sobre todo sin incluir a las orillas
entonces regresemos a nuestra pregunta
original que está aquí
cuál es el dominio de ge inversa así que
veamos el dominio de g inversa e inversa
el dominio de esto puedo poner cualquier
número real aquí
cual
cualquier número real
y lo que esto va a devolver es algo
entre menos pies sobre 2 ipi sobre 2
pero ellos no nos están preguntando el
rango de g inversa que de hecho eso
hubiera sido una pregunta más
interesante nos están preguntando cuál
es el dominio de g inversa entonces
puedo poner cualquier número real en el
lugar de la x entonces pongamos eso aquí
el dominio de heim versa de x es
infinito negativo a infinito pero
realmente y esto es sólo por diversión
solamente hay que verificar que tengamos
la respuesta correcta y así fue
pero sólo por diversión y tengo la
curiosidad veamos cuál es el rango de g
inversa
entonces el rango de esta cosa de aquí
va a estar entre menos pi sobre 2
y sobre dos esto es para esta parte de
aquí le voy a agregar tres pisos obreros
entonces el rango para toda la función
el rango para esto de aquí r
rango
en el lado menor si le agregamos 3 y
sobre 2 esto nos va a dar dos pisos
obreros lo que va a ser 3000 sobre 2 - y
sobre 2 nos da dos pisos sobre 2 lo que
es
sólo pi y en el otro lado de pi sobre 23
pi sobre 2 será 4 y sobre 2
2 entonces el rango de g inversa es de
p2p y es abierto no incluye las
fronteras pero en el dominio puedes
poner cualquier valor para x y estará
definido